[Applause]
I'm listening to your beautiful accent
but is it true that the late great John
Singleton that he had you come out here
to do something with the role that's
true uh by by audition number eight
Singleton took me to South Central
opened the car door and said if you
survive you've got the roll
it really was an experience and I was
walking around South Central I had to to
stay in character so I wasn't allowed to
be British and I said to his mother oh
how lovely your hair looks today I'm
just gonna go and you know put some put
this in a bin and she goes John he ain't
from here huh
nearly lost the park but hey six seasons
later here we are season
[Applause]
like I didn't know this is this true
that you're friends with Jay-Z and
Beyonce
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah yeah I've I've been rounding many
times oh my God
what they like because like they are
very embracing of you right like he's
like paternal basically with you a bit
Yeah I I'll be in Miami it's late and
I'll call them up and I'll be like hey I
I can't get a reservation at Carbone
and anyway damn sure you gotta you gotta
win a couple more Emmys before you can
call me at 11 30.
but that is Sweetest
um we we connected in many ways um but
the Super Bowl was really great because
it was like the first time I kind of
connected with with b and you know I had
just walked for Prado which was huge
such a huge moment for me and aren't you
wearing Prada now I am
I just looking real good I need a new
campaign thank you for that plug
and I know that you have a close
connection with your sister is it I
believe yes and you have a special
connection with tuxedos yes and is it
true that your sister did something with
you in a tuxedo
so when I was a kid right like four five
six years old my mother would always
dress me in these tuxedos for my
birthday the cue is yes but what was
borderline insane was my sister she
would make me marry her Dole Wendy yes
well I got married many times in honor
of your sister would you ever consider
marrying a doll in a tuxedo right now
[Music]
um so
[Applause]
damn said
um I was just wondering
um I know you're in Prada oh my Lord by
the way my daughter is in crutches so
I'm actually really good at getting
people dressed
um so what's happening right now
um this is what we do on the show we're
silly and we like to have fun and what
also is a special connection to this
particular doll her name is Courtney but
I call her Courtney
when we la oh hello
[Applause]
wow look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
so
um Samson when we launched our show we
launched in a pandemic and um nobody
could come on the show and so we didn't
have an audience we didn't have guests
and I would talk to Courtney a lot and I
was wondering if you would marry her
sure Courtney
okay so what would your sister do would
it be like damson would you take the
Courtney to be your lawfully wedded wife
I do
Brittany would you take the Dapper
gentlemanly talented wonderful damson to
be your lawfully wedded husband of which
you'd be so lucky oh
[Applause]
we'll be right back
thank you
[Music]